the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay we're going to get started the
homework does everybody have a copy of
the handout not there's some of the
steps there's there's muddy cards on the
steps and they're going to do three
things today
that's this complex problem I want to
talk about a problem on center of
percussion and then as we have time I'm
going to summarize some summarizing
statements about imbalances which we've
talked a lot about off and on so let's
wait I want you to restrain looking at
the notes I've handed out the notes I've
handed out are this complex problem and
you'll let you look at them in a minute
but I want to get you to think about
some things before you see what's on the
notes but the notes are intended so that
you don't have to spend a lot of time
writing down messy stuff you can think
and listen and they'll also be sent out
on the web so that what is posted so you
don't have to grab a copy for your
friends because I only made 100 copies
in 122 of you okay so let's start with
this problem this is a basically a
complex system math a pendulum and it
when you I've made up one for you so
here's my here's the pendulum it's on an
axle stuck into my cart the carts got
Springs connecting to it and it
naturally has some damping so this is a
realization of what's been drawn there
so let's just give it a little bump cart
moves back and forth pendulum swings
back and forth if I start it this way
you lack a lot more crazy you'll have
more chaotic looking kind of motion the
reason for that which has to do with
this is a multiple degree of freedom
system has more than one natural
frequency as more than one frequency it
responds all mixed together and that's
why it it'll do kind of crazy things
like that'll stop almost stop and then
start up again stuff like that all
completely natural and but if I give it
a nice gentle start it actually mostly
vibrates in what I call one mode of
vibration okay so that's that's we want
to get the equations of motion of this
so I've the drawn here I've drawn it and
the first question about a system like
this when you go to analyze it is how
many degrees of freedom does it have
right so I'm going to this I'm going to
clock just claim this to be a planar
motion problem it's confined to the
board and confined to rotation
perpendicular to the board okay anytime
that happens the each object has at most
three degrees of freedom X Y and the
rotation so we've can we said no
rotations around X or around Y so three
possible ones for this mess three
possible ones for this mess and the then
we start looking for the constraints in
addition well this one is constrained it
can't move out of the out of the see
we've already constrained that way to
say I don't want to say this this one is
certainly constrained in the Y because
of the track here so that's one
constraint we're starting off with six
possible we've got one because it's
constrained in the why the but it can
certainly move in the X can it rotate in
the Z this big mass so that's two so
that out of the three possible the top
one only has one possible degree freedom
X this one also has three possible
degrees of freedom it's pinned at a what
does that give what does that do for
constraints
- this one take 30 seconds to need talk
to your neighbor how many constraints
tis caused by the pin at a
all right so how many believe that
there's one constraint provided by the
pen today let's see then hands that
believe we have one get them up high up
high now how about two okay how about
three all right a little uncertainty
here all right we do you know the motion
today have you prescribed the motion
today in any way in what way do you
never have have to move the block we
borrow given the other block ay
coordinate what is it
so if you know X do you know the motion
today okay so you establish the motion
of a so if you know a you don't need
anything additional information about
eighty it's already been you've already
chosen a coordinate for it so if a is
prescribed that means x1 and y1 the
motion the coordinates describing this
thing and I've given it a started at a
center of mass a little x1 that way a
little y1 that way those are my did
possible displacement coordinates and it
as a rotation coordinate three possible
degrees of freedom right x and y are
prescribed at this point if you
prescribe the motion of fix the motion
of at any point on a rigid body what
does that say about motion translational
motion anyplace else on the rigid body
there's a bad subtle definition of it
what we mean by translation what we mean
by rotation parallel motion trip the
translation part of this every point on
the object moves parallel to every other
point so if you prescribed
if you prescribed the translation of any
one point you have prescribed the
translation for all so this second body
basically it's only translation that it
can have is X of the main body so you
have confined it in X and y has no X&Y
possibilities those are two constraints
leaving you with one right one degree
freedom and we use and then we pick a
coordinate for it and the natural one to
use for that is the angle here so we
need two two coordinates completely
describe the motion it'll yield two
equations of motion so I've you know on
quizzes that you see how many
independent degrees of freedom are there
that is the same question as saying how
many equations of motion are required to
completely describe this system or how
many independent coordinates are
required to completely describe the
motion of the system they're all through
the same question so don't let that back
through a couple of people on the last
quiz okay let's move on to Freebody
diagrams so we now we know we've got two
coordinates theta and X and now you're
free to look at your you can free look
at things and I don't want you spend
most your time thinking and listening
and not having to write but make notes
as you get insights about things
Freebody diagram then two of them the
the pendulum piece is actually pretty
simple
you got mg down and you have two
possible forces at this point of
rotation and I've just named them f1 and
f2 and I've drawn them not arbitrarily
but I've dropped picked the direction to
draw them in I don't know what direction
they're in and that's my complete free
body diagram if I've missed anything
tell me or if you have any questions
about it ask me okay the free body
diagram for this guy
this is capital M this one's m1 that's
which is mass m2 just to keep it
straight
lots of possible forces in this thing
reaction forces through the wheels
they're only vertical I've left out
friction rig Nord friction but also
these f1 and f2 acted to pin and notice
I've drawn them exactly equal and
opposite to these kind of a key thing to
do and why do we do that there's a law
what law do sir you got to do that or
else it won't work
okay these are common unknowns but
they're equal and opposite at this point
and we have an m1 G hanging down the
spring force resists any positive motion
spring pulls back any positive velocity
this the damper holds back and that's
the all of the forces on this thing it's
going to be necessary to be able to
break these things down because I'm
going to some things I'm going to need
to have bits and pieces of F 2 and F 1
so cosine Thetas and sine Thetas now I
don't don't try to resist looking at
your paper for a second next concept
question we talked a lot in the last
couple of lectures about the best
approach to do problems right especially
using angular momentum you think you're
going to need some angular momentum to
solve this problem an approach using
torques and angular momentum
more than likely anytime things are
rotating more than likely so what's the
best approach here
do you so are we going to compute
angular momentum with respect to a at
pivot point with respect to G the center
of mass and it's not too obvious I'm
just so let's say if you were starting
out this problem how would you begin it
would you decide I'm going to
my son my torques around point a or I'm
going to sum my torques around gee did I
mark G yeah it's right it's right right
at the center all right
think about that for a second it got a
question all right I'm going to I'm
gonna do this any questions about the
question I didn't want you to want a
real show of hands here I want to just
you know what would you do to start with
so how many would some torques compute
angular momentum with respect to point a
okay
how about G hmm interesting and it would
another way are you somebody holding
back on me
not everybody raise your hands here okay
all right most people do it around a a
would work okay G would work too and in
fact I first when I sat down to do this
problem I did it with a first and then I
went and did it with G & G turns out
that doing it with respect to G is just
slightly easier okay so the approach we
need to find two equations of motion we
have two bodies we're going to do use
Newton's and Euler's laws to go after
them so the starting out first one some
of the forces in the x-direction on this
body there's a lot of it you know
there's a lot of unknowns so I'm going
to end up and start off with more than
two equations because I've got how many
unknowns one two three four X the motion
X 5 and the angle theta six
I can I can need as many as six
equations to start with if I sum forces
in the vertical direction I can this
turns out that n1 and n2 here I never
actually have to deal with and I'm going
to don't so don't start there if you
think it might not have to mess with
them don't start there going to waste a
lot of time I don't think I'm going to
have to deal with them in fact I'm only
going to need four and to find four
equations involving f1 f2 X and theta
okay
so here's how I'm saving a little time
today I've written it down for you and
I've written it out same same thing on
your on your paper let's talk about the
first one this is the sum of forces in
the capital this capital X direction
which is our inertial frame X on the
main cart on mass 1 so it's got to be
the mass times the acceleration and this
is not and I don't know how that sneaked
in there and I've called it in capital I
had Direction okay mass times
acceleration I just sum up all the
forces on the cart
spring force holds back the direction of
the arrow on my Freebody diagram tells
you the sense of it minus KX minus BX
dot plus f2 cosine theta plus f1 sine
theta all in the X I hat direction okay
some of the forces on my little bar here
in the x1 direction X 1 is down here and
y1 it's off that way so some of the
forces in X 1 is now on mass 2 must be
the mass the semester that its mass
times its acceleration and I've just
called it is that its end any doesn't
matter which where I do my what point
I'm going to do angular momentum with
respect to this is Newton's law and it's
a mass it's the acceleration of centre
of the gravity with respect to an
inertial frame but this is in the little
I hat direction so what I want it's the
component in that direction I have a
minus F 1 I in that direction and I have
a plus m2g cosine theta I in the I hat
direction
pretty straightforward Newton's second
law again the other component for
Newton's in the y1 Direction mass times
the acceleration in the J hat direction
minus f2 Jake is my f2 happens to be in
the minus direction in the free body
diagram minus m2g sine theta in the J
hat and finally I'm going to sum my
moments about the center
of mass it would also work if I did it
around a I would you the reason you
normally do it around a which is why I
started there is why what's the
advantage of doing it around a the
potential advantage of going to a yeah
there f1 and f2 don't generate moments
at the pin and there's a hope that then
you can get what you need to know
without ever having to evaluate f1 and
f2 right and in this case they are
they're going to pop up in these
equations and you're going to have to
deal with them anyway turns out so it
doesn't actually give you much an
advantage so it's easier because the
torque equation is easier in terms of
the number of terms it has that's what
makes it it's slightly easier in this
problem you got to deal with f1 and f2
anyway so it's just a time rate of
change of the angular momentum with
respect to G the and that's external
torques and the only external torque is
caused by f2 and I left out a minus sign
you have it on your paper I think here
no it's correct it's positive so you
have F 2x on a moment arm about g l2 and
it's going to be in the K hat direction
that's the external torque on the system
its gravity causes no torque because
it's acting at the at G right and this
has got to be the time rate of change of
H I claim in this problem you don't have
to you don't have to do this but in this
problem I claim I can write H as a mass
moment of inertia matrix times a vector
that it tells you what the rotation rate
is you in fact can always do this about
G few this is i with respect to G you
know what it is this I I have chosen a
set of chord that's that passed
through the center-of-mass x1 that way
y1 perpendicular to it are they
principal chord and z coming out of the
board are they principal coordinates
sure you know that we've this just a
uniform rod but just symmetry it
immediately should tell you that they
are yes and rotation about a center of
mass you can always do things with the
center of mass okay but you could just
work this out by the basic definition of
angular momentum don't the hard way we
are cross peas and those kind of things
you end up in the same place this one
because it's zero zero Omega Z when you
do the multiplication this is a diagonal
the only term that matters is this one
right so that's going to give us the i
ZZ g theta double dot which is omega z k
hat direction and stop date a double dot
the H gives you theta dot Omega Z is
Theta dot and we've taken the time
derivative which gives us theta double
dot and we know what the mass moment of
inertia about a uniform stick is around
with respect to G ml squared over 12
theta dot
okay so there's our four equations we
have to work with and do they involve in
1 or n 2 not at all that's why I said we
had potentially six we really only have
four unknowns and now the you use these
two to solve for F 1 and F 2 once you
get expressions for F 1 and F 2 you can
eliminate them from here and here and
you're done that's all that's but
there's a bit of a bit of work left to
do that but that's the approach use
these to isolate F 1 and F 2 and plug
them into these two to get your final
equations of motion
but we have a couple of things we don't
know yet that we need in here the
acceleration of that center of mass in
the I hat and in do and break it into
two components I hat in J hat but that's
what we've been to study in kinematics
for so
so we need to know the velocity of G
with respect to O we need to know the
acceleration of G with respect to O okay
so the velocity is pretty straight
forward we'd been this many times it's
the velocity of a with respect to work
from and you try to make as few as
possible things you don't know or put
them in forms that we know how to go
about getting it these are vectors do we
know the velocity of a with respect to O
what's a a is the place where the pin is
what's its velocity at that point next
stop and in what direction okay so this
is X dot capital I hat and now this term
the velocity of G with respect to a this
is a rigid body which is rotating and
translating and we've run into this
before right and there is the basically
the equation for such things is it's the
motion of the the translational velocity
of the object plus the velocities within
the object including anything
contributed by rotation so this term is
the velocity of the point G with respect
to a to the center view with a velocity
of the centre G with respect to point a
and that is right it consistently here
this is the velocity of G with respect
to a evaluated if you had no rotation
this is the if you're sitting the other
way the books often said this is what
you would see if you are on the object
sitting at a looking at G is it moving
you'd say no well
another way of saying that that's the
velocity of this thing if there are no
rotation right so this term happens to
be 0 plus Omega I'll write again dove
doing this on purpose we know this is
Omega Z in the I in the K direction but
reminding you the making has always
respect to the inertial frame cross R G
a the position vector from between the
two points and this so this case we end
up with in X dot I hat Plus this is
going to be Omega Z K cross L over two
little I hat K cross I is J so X dot I
hat this is in this little J moving
coordinate system direction Omega Z is
theta dot theta dot L over 2 J hat I've
kind of made honey I didn't leave enough
room here this is X dot I plus okay
familiar R R Omega term so that's your
velocity of G with respect to O we need
to find an acceleration of that same
point and we're going to take the
derivative of this to get it a point to
remind to we haven't talked about this
in a while
this has mixed unit vectors right it's
got unit vectors in the inertial frame
the unit vectors in the rotating frame
is that allowed no problem perfectly
legitimate right you have to reduce it
eventually
get a workable equation but that's just
fine at this intermediate stage okay
the next thing you want to do is find
this a with respect to G a B with
respect to O the acceleration and we
know that's just a derivative derivative
remember with respect to the inertial
frame that's why we get the F to deal
with this rotation business of velocity
of G with respect to O but the
derivative of this does I change
direction nope so this is just X double
dot and we have a single term here that
we have to take a derivative of so we
get a theta double dot L over two J this
is a little lowercase J but now this J
rotate yeah and so this is the
derivative of a rotating vector they
rotate the derivative of J minus theta I
so minus theta dot squared L over 2 I
hat
all right and that's all there is to
getting gee now we could have done I'm
going to rumata this lips one that one I
don't want you to be afraid of using the
big kind of hairy looking vector 3d
vector equation for acceleration
acceleration and this gives color this
is a with respect to O putting it in
terms of this problem plus the
acceleration of G with respect to a
evaluated with no rotation plus Omega
dot cross R GA plus Omega cross Omega
cross R GA - Omega cross velocity GA
Omega equals zero and I should have one
two three four five terms as always five
potential terms when you're evaluating
the acceleration of a point on a rigid
body which is translating and rotating
this is translating and rotating
reference frames attached you know on a
ridge attached to the rigid body and
then you just go in and fill it in this
is the acceleration of the rigid body
the translational acceleration and this
problem what is that powder okay this
guy is capital X double dot I hat right
this is the acceleration of point G
relative to a if you were in the object
on the
it is alright zero this is a the oil
Aryan term this is Theta double dot
crossed with the distance from the
between the two points is this zero no
not necessarily so this is Theta double
dot this is the L over 2 that's this and
when you do the cross-product of K and I
you get J that's that term Omega cross
Omega cross RGA this is the centripetal
term what do you think it's going to be
zero
nope so this is K cross I as j k trois j
is i - this is the term - gives you
minus theta dot squared L over 2 I and
this is our Coriolis term it requires
motion of that point G relative day is
that moving nope so this terms goes to 0
get the same answer all right so don't
be afraid of this this thing just bleh
it down just plug things in and the
right things will fall out
all right on the paper I break this I
break down a with the acceleration of G
with respect to O into its little ID and
little J components and I end up with
acceleration of G with respect to O I
group the terms the I capital X double
dot sine theta actually have to break
this see this is not in the direction of
little I or Little J so I use the I know
that I can express capital I as a
lowercase I sine theta plus J cosine
theta and I use that so it's X double
dot sine theta minus L over 2 theta dot
squared it is in the little I hat
direction so this is the I hat term plus
x double-dot cosine theta plus L over
two theta double dot and this is the J
hat term okay yep eyes you know this you
have to always have these same decisions
to make that's what you're comfortable
with what you think is going to lead to
the least work you have no idea how much
time I spent working on this problem to
put it in a form that I thought I could
teach it to you it's been a lot of time
on it
the point being occasionally you have to
spend a lot of time working them out
going down a path that doesn't pay off
backing up going down the next one on
quizzes on homework most of what stops
you from getting to the final right
answer is confidence you got to believe
that you've learned these things well
enough that you know this is the right
thing to do and it'll get you there is
do the arithmetic right okay and we all
make little mistakes and you all have to
back up and do it again but that's why
the fundamentals on understanding the
basic concepts are so important
you got the concepts down cold you'll
have confidence that your method is
going to work okay so I've got a this is
my idol lie Direction term this is my J
Direction term I can take those and take
this bit and plug it in here let's just
give it a name let's call this a and
this piece here B a goes right here
that's a and this is B okay and now
you've made that substitution you can
solve for f1 and they're all in one
direction now they're all in the little
I had direction you make the other
substitution everything's in little J
hat and you can drop them you no longer
have to carry it along you now have
scalar equations you can solve for f1
and f2
so that is that's done and you take
those two expressions so this implies F
1 equals and this one implies F 2 equals
and you take those and you put F 1 and F
2 you need F 1 and F 2 and you plug it
in here and in this equation you only
need an F 2 and when you do that you get
your two equations of motion now a
couple things happen it turns when you
do this when you make the substitution
in here you end up with an M X double
dot cosine squared theta and an M 2 X
double dot sine squared theta and sine
squared plus cosine squared
conveniently equals 1 and that collapses
and goes away so you end up with
the two final expressions here after
you've made those combinations so from
four over here I'll call it four prime
you get one of your equations of motion
that's one equation of motion it's
primarily about the translation of the
me rotation of the system come it drives
from all those substitutions in this
equation
curiously these two bits go together
which if you had worked around a and
used dangerously perhaps the parallel
axis theorem able to add ended up with
ml squared over three that's your first
equate as one of your equations of
motion and from the first one the forces
that comes from the sum of the forces on
the main mass m1 plus m2 X double dot
plus B X dot plus K X all the usual just
things for a mass spring oscillator but
now you've got these additional forces
that are exerted on that because it's
got this pendulum flag and back and
forth
and if I made a mistake on the board
believe the paper I think I've got it
all transcribed right this is your force
equation on the main mass it's the if
you didn't have the pendulum hanging
there there's your equation of motion
for not just in a cart going back and
forth with Springs then you have this
pendulum hanging on it which requires
which puts additional forces on it they
come through those f1 and f2 terms and
then you can see they have to do with
having to accelerate things down there
okay now these two equations are
actually quite easy to linearize so
linearize means you can always linearize
around the equilibrium position this is
its equilibrium position small motions
that can be described what you see there
by linearized equations of motion and to
linearize so for theta small sine theta
is approximately equal to theta cosine
theta is approximately equal to 1 and
you just have sines and cosines in here
let this guy go to 1 you let this go to
theta here 1 here theta and you have
linearized equations of motion now other
problems are it can be harder to
linearize but this is particularly
simple two linear equations solvable if
you solve them they'll give you two
natural frequencies for the system and
two vibration modes all right that's the
end of this problem any last questions
about it I'm going to move on to this
topic of center of percussion
okay this next one's kind of fun it has
a real practical purpose in life I
didn't bring my tennis racket or my
baseball back but if any of you if any
of you play sports that use things that
hit things you know there's a gun you
hit the baseball and you hit it that
down on the handle it really stings your
hands right or the tennis racket if you
don't hit it right it just whew feel a
lot of forces in your hands and you hit
it with really sweet you feel almost no
force at all how many have had that
experience really common okay so is
there a right place to hit it the answer
is yes and we're going to go through
that right now so here's our I'm looking
down here's my baseball bat Z is in this
direction this is kind of the top view
so here's my handle of my bat balls
coming in put some force on it I think I
put it lower case in the notes okay and
I want to know and I want to minimize
that force at my hands I'm going to call
this place where it hits P I'm going to
say here's its center of mass at G point
about which you're holding it and it's
rotating is a and my coordinate system
attached to the bat remember we always
attach you always have this coordinate
system attached to the bat and it's
rotational problems so that we can
divine things like moments of inertia so
it's a coordinate system attached to the
bat and here's my Y direction and Z's
coming out of the board and this
distance is going to be important to me
our GA and this distance here I'm going
to call Q it's my unknown and I want to
know where the boy is the sweet spot
what do I want Q to be so that I
minimize the force point at where I'm at
a where I'm hanging on
so how many degrees of freedom how many
independent coordinates do I need to do
this problem this frogs complicated
because it's a you know real-life
situation it's quite complicated and I'm
going to do a lot of simplification and
claim ly the answer and then look at the
answer and say does it make sense where
mice did my simplifications make sense
so I'm going to make this I'm going to
do a number of simplifications I'm going
to argue that I think I can get at most
of the answer by essentially saying
right here where I'm hitting it my
wrists are like hinge point that's point
a I'm going to assume it rotates about a
fixed point at that moment okay pretty
gross simplification of the real thing
going on you really have muscles just
putting moments on it your wrists
actually are moving some but I'm just
going to say rotating only about that
point it stays in this plane
it's a planar motion problem at most
three possible degrees of freedom XY and
sub theta right and I'm going to make
the simplification that is pinned at a
so if it's pin today what is that how
many constraints is that two one left so
I only need I'm going to pick one
coordinate that's going to be my theta
so even though I've made these gross
simplifications will the answer actually
turn out to be meaningful and this G is
my center of mass and let's assume that
we know I Z Z with respect to G that is
mass moment of inertia for rotation is Z
okay assume that we know that given so
for this problem the when you have fixed
rotation points the last that this
problem here that a point wasn't fixed
it was moving accelerating it could have
had lots of complicated terms in its
expression for torque if you
Phil done it that way this is fixed
today makes a lot of sense to compute
moments about a alright so my first
equation here that I want is some of the
moments torques with respect to a and
these are well they'll all turn out to
be in the Z direction here and they are
time rate of change of the angular
momentum with respect to G which in
these planar motion problems always then
boils down to the mass moment of inertia
for the axis you're rotating about times
the angular acceleration that's that
term oops not G a excuse me we picked
our point we're going to stick with it
here okay I need that and this is in the
K hat direction
is the only only term in our torque
equation what are the external torques
well now Z's out of the board like this
I've got a force acting on a moment arm
giving me a torque in the other
direction so this is minus F Q also K
hat
now I might have done this sooner but we
should look at a free body diagram so
here's a little stick figure of my bat
and I potentially have an unknown force
in the y-direction are Y and another
unknown force in the X direction here at
a at pin point where it's rotating it
about out here is G and a G is there an
M is there an mg term well Crowley right
but it's acting it's in the minus Z
direction and I'm this is I'm still I'm
looking down on it this is the top view
so gravity would create a moment in the
Y direction and I don't need I don't I
don't have to deal with that my only
moment this is my fort isn't my torque
equation only has K hat terms in it
gravity creates a a moment in the Y
which in fact you have to that's a
static equilibrium problem you do have
to provide that when you hold on the bat
or else the bat would droop right
doesn't have anything to do with the
dynamics actually okay here's here's G
there's no gravity term that you can see
it's pointing into the board and out
here is my point P and here's F okay so
I need an equation I have equation for
moment equilibrium I need aid some
dynamic equation I have two possible
equations for force equilibrium how many
unknowns do I have
but no others three possible unknowns
I'm going to need three equations to get
rid of these two terms right and I'm
looking ahead my objective is to make
that term go to zero so I both have to
find the expression for and then figure
out how to make it go to zero that's
all--that's that's how you do this
problem okay so that from let's do some
of the forces in the Y so you have an R
Y J hat - F also in the J hat direction
and that's basically all there is to
that but that must be the mass of the
bat times the acceleration of G with
respect to O in the Y direction so
that's our J hat component
it's just component of acceleration in
the J hat direction and the sum of the
forces in the X we look at those well we
have an Rx in the eye and there are no
others and that must be then the mass of
the bat times the acceleration G with
respect to O of the bit in the X
direction and that'll be in the I hat so
I've got two unknown accelerations now
to have to deal with but we know lots of
kinematics now
so let's do it this way just to give you
the practice acceleration of G with
respect to O acceleration of a with
respect to O plus the acceleration of G
with respect to a Omega equals 0 plus
Omega dot cross RGA plus 2 Omega cross V
G a omega equals 0 and finally plus
Omega cross Omega cross R G a 1 2 3 4 5
terms our vector 3d equation is figured
out quickly what's this term
0y pigs point of rotation that's our
assumption this guy goes to zero huh
okay
the velocity genes affect a zero Omega
dot cross RGA so that you know there's
an expanded our toleration which there
might be cross our that's a perfectly
legitimate term and that'll give you a
this will give you a theta double dot
just like before it's in the K Direction
cross our G a in the I that's this term
right here okay this velocity of G with
respect to a on the bat went to zero the
Coriolis that goes away so at this point
I've only got one term from there and
this term is our centripetal term I
think there's going to be a centripetal
force rotating about a point if the
center of mass is not the point of
rotation you will have you will be make
forcing a mass to move in a circle and
that always requires a centripetal
acceleration always requires a force
this for sure will give you a term which
is a minus Omega Z squared type term
times the are the distance RG a that's
its radius and its inward so in this
direction it will be I hat three terms
same as before
we now have our accelerations
okay so from our top equation up there
from the summation of forces in the Y
will now substitute these in we have em
RG a J hat the acceleration term see we
ended up with the theta the K cross I
term gives you J so the oil Arian term
is going to show up here so that we need
a theta double dot and this is in the J
direction that comes from the the
acceleration we figured out and that's
equal to minus F plus ry and this is all
little J hat let me write the other one
first here here's the summation in the X
direction its mass times our
acceleration in the I hat direction in
what term we only ended up with one term
doing that and that's our centripetal
term so we get minus our G a theta dot
squared I hat that's the centripetal
acceleration times the mass and the only
term that it is equated to is the other
reaction force okay so here's the
careers ik here's the key step in this
problem we want what to be zero so that
we're hitting it at the sweet spot
what's the original objective well we
don't we want our Y to go away all right
make it go away
so f then
I'll do it as an intermediate step just
say F is then I'm going to leave our Y
for just a second longer are y minus M
our GA theta double dot and since this
is my accomplish a hat this is now
scalar equation I can find an expression
for this force that I don't know what
the force is but the ball exerts on the
bat but it exists I can say this it must
be true and my objective is that this
should be zero so that says when that's
true F is minus M RGA theta double dot
and I'm going to use that in just a
moment so I'm going to substitute this
into our first equation up there for
moment equation number one so this
implies that F is minus M RG with
respect to a theta double dot and this
goes into one which I have an F Q so I
do that or nope
this is now also a scalar equation I can
drop the K hats so I Z with respect to a
theta double dot equals minus f qk minus
F cube but F is minus so the minus is
canceled so I get M R G a theta double
dot times Q now I Z Z with respect to a
can be expressed as
M times something we call the radius of
gyration squared with respect and that
this has got to be with respect to a the
radius of gyration for rotation about a
I can find an expression like this so
that it's equal to I is easy about with
respect to a on all the radius of
gyration means is if I took all the mass
and put it that distance away the mass
moment of inertia of that concentrated
point mass with respect to the point of
rotation is the same as in the real
object so this is just a you know
convenience that we use so that's M
Kappa squared and that says then that M
Kappa squared a equals M R G a theta
double dot I have a theta double dot
here - sorry times Q and I can solve for
Q the theta double dots go away M's go
away and Q is just Kappa squared a
divided by R G a so let's
and that's the exodus that's the answer
to this center of percussion problem
here's your bat here's a here's G here's
P the Q is about here whoops excuse me Q
is the distance to P it's always outside
of G you'll always be outside of G well
let's think about maybe reason for that
so here's the center of mass here's our
G a and here's this point at which you
want to hit it the sweet spot and it's
always Kappa square to a over RGA now
you how could you how do you get to
Kappa squared a well you need to
evaluate izc with respect to a but i ZZ
with respect to a you can do parallel
axis theorem as easy with respect to G
Plus M RGA squared right and you have
that so if we were to do this I'll give
you a quick example if this were a
uniform rod I ZZ g equals ml squared
over 12 eyes easy with respect to a ml
squared over 12 plus M R G with respect
to a squared that is ml squared over 12
plus M L squared this is L over 2 to RG
a half the length if I put a right at
the end so I'm doing this simple rod but
a right here G right in the middle so
this is L over 2 ml squared over 2
squared 4 you add those two together you
get ml squared over 3 equals M Kappa a
squared so Kappa squared a is l squared
over 3 and Q equals l squared over 3
divided by L over 2 so you get 2/3
well 2/3 of the length which you out
here well half the length so here's a
hell over - here's p @ 2l over 3 so
anytime you run into this radius of
these center of percussion problems
tennis racket baseball bats whatever the
right place to hit it is away from the
point of rotation now do you think this
is now how good this model
you know is it you start thinking about
well one of the things you know does the
bat handle is really moving it's still
actually remarkably good remarkably good
in fact you know if the fact these other
things are happening like you're putting
some moment on with your wrists the fact
that you still have some speed down here
all you're doing is kind of maybe
changing the point it's rotating around
but you're still having to exert forces
with your hands at that point where
you're holding it and you just want
those forces to go to zero the all of
these other complications you're still
going to find out to make that force to
go to zero it's approximately that
pretty good really a pretty good answer
all right
ah let's go back and and we have we we
have another piece of information that
we developed in this problem that we
haven't used we had another equation we
had the acceleration in the I direction
and it's just equal to RX m the RX force
is M times the acceleration in the I
direction and that's minus our G with
respect to a theta dot squared that's
our own centripetal force term right
centrifugal force centripetal
acceleration here's a centripetal
acceleration times the mass is the force
to make that to make the bat go in a
circle you have to provide that force
okay
so I want to finish up by a loose end
that many people have continued to have
a little trouble with because I get
questions on muddy cards about this and
it was on this last homework I don't
know how that wheel with a little bit
missing if you all got that sorted out
if you're all perfectly clear in your
mind about that then I don't need to say
what I'm going to talk about for a
second but I thought I would tidy
just tied it up and glass a little bit
here this problem is a nice lead to it
this last force that I computed is the
force required to swing this thing in a
circle and I'm putting that force right
here I'm saying it's actually the point
of rotation is right here and that force
is the mass times the acceleration of
that point and that point is a distance
from my point of rotation to the center
of mass no accident you're accelerating
the center of mass that times the
rotation rate squared is the
acceleration the centripetal
acceleration this is the force so the
anytime you have an object
maybe it's a wheel and maybe it has
stuck on it a little extra mass you
don't know about it rock stuck in your
tire this is the center of rotation your
axle in your wheel doesn't move tire
doesn't move relative to the axle you've
got this little bit of mass missing or
added doesn't much matter the center of
mass of this system is no longer at the
center of rotation so I'll call the
center of rotation here a that's what
it's rotating about this addition or
loss of a piece of mass makes the center
of mass of the system move a little bit
of an active an extra little bit of mass
out here the new actual center of
gravity of the system is out here is a
little distance away and I'll get call
that distance e eccentricity so now I
have a system whose center of mass is it
not at the center of rotation and its
distance RG a is I'm calling it the
eccentricity the and as this rotates now
I'll put a coordinate system on here I
XY rotating with the system the force
it's going to appear here on this axle
it's going to have a force that I'll
call RX RX equals the mass times the
acceleration of the center of gravity of
the system and the center acceleration
of the center of gravity in this system
is minus e
theta dot squared and it's inward in the
I hat direction therefore the minus sign
so the force this is the centripetal
acceleration times mass the force
required to make it do that is an inward
force minus M e theta dot squared I have
okay
I drew our X in a positive direction the
answer comes out - it says it's going
the other way
so this is always the case if you have a
system that for some reason is does not
rotate about its true center of mass but
in fact the center of mass is off a
little bit or a lot you will have to
provide a force that's inwardly directed
is that thing spins okay now they a
subtlety I want you to know really go
away with is that we've talked quite a
lot about unbalance due to these masses
that aren't that the concentrated at the
center these these unbalanced masses
there are two kinds of unbalanced that
engineers have chosen to describe the
world with two kinds one is static
imbalance and the other is dynamic
imbalance a statically imbalanced system
is one in which you can if you this time
looking a side view of an edge view of
this thing as it's spinning maybe like
this and the center of rotation is here
and the
G is here that force is inward on it but
I've it's really it's perfectly
symmetric so this is this force that I'm
having to provide to keep this thing
from flying off is perfectly inward
directed does it generate any moments
about this point none this is called
static imbalance and that is here's an
example of static imbalance this is my
rotor I'm going to put it on its side
gravity says I want this to hang down
because where's the center of mass of
this system up here along here it's down
here somewhere right
that's center of mass you do a statics
calculation mg sine-theta you know it's
going to hang down so that's why they
call it static imbalance and the way you
can correct a statically imbalanced
system is just do the test put the thing
hang the thing on an axle and do I have
a handy axle here today put it on an
axle and see if it rotates and if it
wrote always rotates to some point
hanging down you know this thing
statically imbalanced and look at my kit
of parts here let's maybe do this I
don't know if this is heavy enough to do
the job but now I've put a little bit of
mass on here and I presume that if I do
this with it okay it goes down the
system is statically imbalanced this
system now is also dynamically
unbalanced why it kind of depends on
where I do the calculation but if I do
Mike if I say that I want to know this
one I put a force a mass off-center here
and if I compute moments about a point
that's perfect
lined up with it
this system will create no moments about
that point this system perfectly
balanced now the mass that I've stuck on
here is there this system is perfectly
balanced it generates no moments as it
spins no matter where you calculate this
point but this extra little bit if I put
my if I compute this is a if I compute H
with respect to a here and do the
derivatives uh but I get no torques
except in the Z direction but as soon as
I move away from there and there is a
distance here and I compute moments
about that do I get some static moments
that not in the direction that's been
yes so when you do that this system if
I'm if this is my point a let's call it
it over here this M this system is it
statically imbalanced yep is it
dynamically imbalance yeah so how would
you balance it final question of the
term for me how would you balance put
the system into balance
all right so if I put another mass here
will that statically balanced it
statically balanced meaning if I let go
it will rotate well will they have to
rotate around and find a low point so
any low point if I put it one equal and
opposite equal just it's a way opposite
side would it be statically balanced
yeah because gravity pulls down on this
one equal and opposite down on this one
so it would be statically balanced would
it be dynamically balanced the system is
you spin will try to twist like this so
it's not dynamically back what if I move
it over to here is it statically
balanced is it dynamically balanced
compute the torques you know you put
let's put a right in the center compute
the angular momentum take its time
derivative and you will find that this
one as it spins tries to create a moment
like that and this one as it spins tries
to create a moment like that and there
are exactly equal and opposite this is
that this is dynamically balanced and
statically balanced this is not dynamic
if you put a right in the usual center
the original center of gravity will call
a of this wheel this system is not
dynamically balanced with respect to an
a that's right on the axle and on the
center because it has this little offset
okay